the jurogan experience let's take this
opportunity to give credit to the
sexiest man alive according to guardian
foundry
did you imagine a lot of girls lining up
looking to [ __ ] that guy
hilarious so i don't know if you you
know the the the picture did you see his
pose
yeah yeah what did you think about that
i mean well how the [ __ ] do you have
time to do that aren't you trying to
protect us from the evil i mean when
you're dead
when you're that sexy i guess you just
take a couple seconds to give you a gift
i wanted to give you a gift
i figured if you you know if you were
gonna give me a fouchy doll i already
have no no no i'm not gonna give you a
foul treat i'm gonna give you something
a little more than a fouchy dollar you
know
because of what he just did
i got you tony fauci's tops rookie card
psa 10. he's got this is something i
think you you should keep for real yeah
i mean that probably we just probably
increased the value by five times right
now just by talking about it that's
actually a card for fauci
and uh see that can you see that
he's throwing a pitch he's throwing a
picture did you see his pitch
uh i would imagine it was atrocious you
got to see the pitch i don't know if you
can show it you cannot right you can't
show it right who had the worst pitch
ever
that's very arguable
50 cent at a bad one 50 seconds
gary delavate you had a bad one oh baba
bowie yeah yeah
oh well yeah anyways i thought you would
appreciate that
you know how much that's worth today
it's probably worth 50 bucks it's worth
a couple hundred dollars really that's
the point that a fouchy baseball cart is
worth worth worth a couple hundred
dollars
but i think it just went up after it
became sexy well that's the sexiest man
in america the sexiest right wow
yeah
whoa it's worth a thousand dollars they
just went up a little bit
[ __ ] on ebay
but there's not a lot of them so no no
no you thank you very much today his his
street credit for his baseball card just
went up yeah with uh with fauci but uh
we'll see what's going to happen there
yeah
how much who the [ __ ] is collecting
cards oh dude are you kidding me do you
know there's a ufc i have a ufc card
that's like worth money i have oh yeah
max holloway's rookie card how much is
it worth
i haven't looked but there i mean the
the card game has
exploded
are you following it at all or no no i
don't have time for that [ __ ] wait
you're you're not following at all
what's going on with the card game no
okay can i can i uh shock you with some
numbers
that's okay with you please okay what do
you think
is
the value the most expensive card in the
world today uh
just throw a number does babe ruth have
a card babe root's got a card but it's
not the most expensive really jackie
robinson he's got a card but it's
probably not in the top 1000 of the most
expensive
oh boy yeah well i'm out of guesses
mickey mantle has a card okay mickey
mantle okay how much is that psa 10
1952 tops rookie card there's only three
of them what do you guess please 20
million bucks 20 million bucks really
that's actually number really so you do
follow cards no i just say that's like
the oh you're on the dot it's 20 million
bucks i'm good at that the guy who
bought it in 1998 the owner of the
diamondbacks paid 104 for it in 1998
from 104 to 20. okay today
a luca credit card a luca rookie car two
days after his birthday
at 22 years old sold for 5.2 million
that's a basketball player joe yeah luca
doncic he's a great basketball player
you don't follow basketball i don't
follow sports i got you yeah so i'm a
sports commentator who doesn't follow
sports dude you got a baseball you got a
card as well you got a card you got a
card with uh i know there's a ufc card
there is i think it's worth some money
yeah of course
yeah you got a card the card industry
today is booming there's a there's a few
guys that are doing it the right way
uh the card private equity business got
into it they got into it so you know
jordan's rookie cards were selling for
like 25 000 bucks a few years ago and
once these pri there's only 330 of those
psa 10 rookie cards these guys got into
it next thing you know jumped
to a couple of them sold for seven
hundred thousand dollars and they can't
fake that can you fake a car well the
best thing about the card game that
changed is there's a grading service
called psa
so psa that's based out of newport they
don't even they're not even taking any
new cards right now because they can't
it takes 12 months for you to get graded
they're that busy right now no joke and
it costs like 50 bucks 40 bucks 100
bucks to get cards graded depending on
the quality of it you send it to them
they look at it
and then based on that like you see this
here that says the psa stamp
they give it a score there's a vin
number to it and then there's a not a
vendor but a serial number to it and
then this has got a value okay wow so
psa changed the game beckett grading
service changed the game watch the
entire episode for free only on spotify